I'VE RUN INTO A SURPRISING
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
I SEEM TO RUB THE WRONG WAY.
- TAKE YOUR PIZZA
AND STICK IT UP YOUR ASS.
- YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE?
YOU REMIND ME OF THE WIZARD
OF LONELINESS.
[not audible]
[pleasant music playing]
- I'M NOT SURE WHY THAT IS,
BUT I KNOW THAT AS A TV HOST
HAVING A PERSONALITY THAT PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE IS BAD FOR BUSINESS.
AND THAT'S WHY
I NEEDED TO MAKE A CHANGE.
SO FOR THE FIRST WEEK OF
SHOOTING MY SHOW THIS SEASON,
I HIRED A FOCUS GROUP
THAT REPRESENTS
A CROSS-SECTION
OF AMERICAN SOCIETY
TO WATCH MY EVERY MOVE
FROM A NEARBY BOX TRUCK.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS.
- WE HAVE THE DOORS.
WE HAVE MAHOGANY WOOD.
- USING A HIDDEN EAR PIECE,
THEY WERE ABLE TO GIVE ME
REAL-TIME FEEDBACK ON THE FLY.
- WE HAVE OAK.
- EXPRESS YOURSELF
WITH YOUR HANDS,
WITH YOUR SHOULDERS,
WITH ANYTHING.
- SO YOU'VE GOT THE BEST PRICES
IN TOWN.
THAT WOULD HELP ME BECOME
A MORE LIKABLE HOST.
WOW.
THAT'S REALLY COOL TO HEAR.
- YEAH.
THERE YOU GO.
- THEY TOLD ME HOW TO ENGAGE
WITH MY AUDIENCE MORE.
- LIKE 500 MODELS OF DOORS
YOU COULD CHOOSE FROM.
- NOW DO YOU MANUFACTURE
ALL THE DOORS IN THIS BUILDING?
- WE MANUFACTURE MOST OF THEM
IN THIS BUILDING, YES.
- THERE YOU GO.
GOOD JOB.
- AND THEY ALSO HAD SOME FASHION
TIPS TO MAKE ME MORE RELATABLE.
- I THINK A V-NECK
WOULD GO WELL WITH YOU.
- A V-NECK?
REALLY?
- A BLAZER.
A T-SHIRT WITH A BLAZER
MIGHT WORK.
- YEAH. THAT'S SORT OF
A POPULAR STYLE RIGHT NOW.
- YEAH.
- THE ONLY ISSUE
WE ENCOUNTERED EARLY ON
WAS THAT IT WAS HARD
FOR THE GROUP TO STAY FOCUSED
WHILE WE WERE MOBILE.
- WHOA!
- OHH...
- BUT WE QUICKLY
FOUND A SOLUTION TO THAT
BY BOLTING DOWN THE TABLES
AND STRAPPING THEM IN
WHILE THE TRUCK WAS MOVING.
[wood creaking]
AS THE WEEK WENT ON,
I WAS ABLE TO EVOLVE MY STYLE
TO BECOME MORE IN LINE
WITH THEIR TASTES,
AND A MORE LIKABLE ME
WAS STARTING TO TAKE SHAPE.
GOOD TO MEET YOU, MAN.
- GOOD TO MEET YOU TOO.
- SO TELL ME ABOUT
YOUR FOOT MASSAGE PARLOR.
- OH, THERE WE GO.
- BODY MOTIONS ARE GREAT.
- WE ALSO DO FACIAL
AND HEAD, TOO.
- NOW, EVERYONE LOVES
A FOOT MASSAGE, RIGHT?
- OH, GREAT.
HE LOOKED OUT AT THE CAMERA.
- GREAT LOOKING AT THE CAMERA.
GOOD JOB.
- THE GROUP WAS ABSOLUTELY
LOVING WHO I WAS NOW.
NOW, IS THAT A SOAPY WATER
OR IS IT JUST
PLAIN WATER?
- JUST THE WATER, JUST CLEAN,
PURE--JUST WATER, YES.
- JUST WATER.
WOW.
THAT'S SO INTERESTING.
- THERE YOU GO.
- GOOD! GOOD.
- AND EVEN THOUGH I WAS STILL
GETTING USED TO IT,
IT SEEMED LIKE I HAD BECOME
A BETTER VERSION OF ME.
BUT BEFORE FULLY COMMITTING
TO THIS,
I WANTED TO PUT
MY NEW PERSONALITY
THROUGH THE ULTIMATE TEST.
AND WE'LL SEE THAT IN A BIT.